Jake:我大充电宝怎么一个都找不到啊
Jake: Why can't I find any of my big power banks?
Jake:他应该有10个
Jake: There should be 10 of them.
Jake:二层我给他塞了
Jake: I stuffed some on the second floor.
Jake:就5个吧
Jake: Just 5 of them.
Jake:剩下5个没了
Jake: The other 5 are gone.
Jake:在哪里呢
Jake: Where are they?
Jake:谢斌竹咱充电宝怎么这么少啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu, why do we have so few power banks?
其他人：上面都有大充电宝
Others: There are big power banks upstairs.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:这太少了
Jake: This is too few.
Jake:昨天昨天一楼充电宝没收完
Jake: Yesterday, the power banks on the first floor weren't all collected.
Jake:哦你还有个20的充电宝
Jake: Oh, you still have a 20,000 mAh power bank.
Jake:他在一边充一边
Jake: He charges it while...
Jake:一边充充电宝一边给电吗
Jake: Charging the power bank and giving power at the same time?
Jake:这真能
Jake: That's really possible.
Jake:你没有朋友我有
Jake: You don't have friends, I do.
Jake:有你有一个朋友啊
Jake: You have a friend.
Jake:呃行但我现在在国内啊
Jake: Uh, alright, but I'm currently in the country.
Jake:我国内我我过来大概要半个月吧
Jake: In the country, it will take me about half a month to get there.
Jake:新加坡移民局
Jake: Singapore Immigration Office.
Tasha: 你放心
Tasha: Don't worry.
Tasha: 今天晚上我一定会把它吃掉的
Tasha: I'll definitely eat it all tonight.
Tasha: 垃圾转移
Tasha: Garbage transfer.
Jake:随自己烤
Jake: Roast it yourself.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:累死我了
Alice: I'm exhausted.
Alice:有早饭吗
Alice: Is there any breakfast?
Katrina: 好久没吃油条了
Katrina: Haven't had fried dough sticks in a long time.
其他人： 你来吗
Others: Are you coming?
Alice:都啥呀
Alice: What do you have?
Tasha: 音响呢不是说拿音响来吗
Tasha: Where's the speaker? Didn't you say you'd bring the speaker?
Tasha: 音响
Tasha: Speaker.
Shure: 购入我们的ego币了是吗
Shure: Did you buy our ego coins?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:准备发售了
Jake: Getting ready for sale.
Jake:我们少了很多充电宝
Jake: We're missing a lot of power banks.
Jake:不知道发生了什么
Jake: No idea what happened.
Tasha: 我还想说我少了很多皮筋呢
Tasha: I was going to say I've lost a lot of hair ties.
Tasha: 我带过来至少10根不下皮筋今天
Tasha: I brought at least 10 hair ties today.
Jake:这充电宝咋还没送呢
Jake: Why haven't the power banks been delivered yet?
Alice:给了我一根
Alice: Gave me one.
Jake:就没了呵呵呵
Jake: And then it's gone, haha.
Tasha: 今天只剩最后一根了
Tasha: Today, there's only one left.
Tasha: 我想扎个双马尾都扎不了
Tasha: I can't even make twin ponytails.
其他人：一觉醒来掉下来了
Others: Woke up and it fell off.
Jake:哦这么少
Jake: Oh, so few.
Jake:牛批
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:炒币呢
Jake: Trading coins?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
其他人：这是拿命玩
Others: This is risking your life.
Jake:波动这么大
Jake: Such big swings.
其他人：就还好昨天晚上蹲到一个点
Others: Luckily, I caught a good point last night.
其他人：蹲到0.18 然后及时死了哦
Others: Hit 0.18, then cashed out in time.
Katrina: 我一直想知道挖币的原理是什么
Katrina: I've always wanted to know how mining works.
其他人：然后你算到了前面多少位
Others: And then you calculate up to a certain point.
其他人：是他指定的保险
Others: It's the insurance he specified.
其他人：你就OK了
Others: Then you're good to go.
Jake:你就碰上了
Jake: You just hit it.
Jake:然后这就是你的了
Jake: And then it's yours.
Katrina: 啊那些程序算那东西啊
Katrina: Ah, those programs calculate that stuff?
其他人：这不是算
Others: It's not just calculation.
Jake:哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, alright.
Jake:他会ban掉你吗
Jake: Will he ban you?
Shure: 我不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Jake:试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Jake:反正你不用
Jake: Anyway, you don't use it.
Jake:他肯定在监控
Jake: He's definitely monitoring.
Katrina: 那它这个币的价格怎么去呢
Katrina: So how does the price of this coin go?
其他人：币的价格就是共存在你的
Others: The price of the coin is shared in your...
Katrina: 啊就是看你挖到那别人有没有挖到
Katrina: Ah, it depends on whether others have mined it?
Katrina: 就同同个时间多少人
Katrina: Like how many people at the same time.
其他人：这个币的价值在于你觉得这个币未来
Others: The value of this coin depends on if you think it has a future.
其他人：嗯你觉得大家都觉得这个比未来好
Others: Hmm, if everyone thinks it has a future.
其他人：那他不就更实际吗
Others: Then it becomes more practical.
其他人：比如说我们ego币
Others: Like our ego coin.
其他人：一开始一分不值
Others: Initially worth nothing.
其他人：但大家在二手物品非常的屌哎
Others: But everyone finds it great for second-hand items.
其他人：这ego币就很有价值
Others: Then ego coin becomes valuable.
其他人：可能一开始刚拍
Others: Maybe at first, just...
其他人：拍第一轮是将10个一个币
Others: The first round was 10 coins for one.
其他人：后来大家越来越少
Other person: Later, there were fewer and fewer people.
其他人：突然有一个杀掉一个
Other person: Suddenly, someone killed another person.
其他人：一个币就换下了一个大东西
Other person: One coin could exchange for a big thing.
其他人：然后整体就升值
Other person: Then the whole thing appreciated in value.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:虽然不知道
Jake: Although I don't know
Jake:但是听起来不是
Jake: But it doesn't sound like it.
Alice:有人喝粥吗
Alice: Does anyone want porridge?
Alice:我想喝咸的
Alice: I want something salty.
Jake:喝喝呵呵呵
Jake: Drink, drink, hahaha
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Haha
Alice:银耳吧
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 皮蛋瘦肉粥
Katrina: Century egg and lean meat porridge.
Alice:嗯我想喝咸的
Alice: Yeah, I want something salty.
Alice:拿个碗倒一下
Alice: Get a bowl and pour it.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:你看他是要在群里发的
Jake: Look, he's going to post it in the group.
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Oh my god, oh my god.
Jake:哈哈哈壮观哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, so spectacular, hahaha.
Alice:有碗吗
Alice: Do we have bowls?
Alice:那个里面没了
Alice: There's none left in there.
Jake:刷卡
Jake: Swipe the card.
其他人：okay in your
Other person: Okay, in your
Jake:手机号
Jake: Phone number.
Katrina: 勺子的
Katrina: For the spoon.
Jake:overseas Chinese bank
Jake: Overseas Chinese bank.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Jake:但是他没有眼镜
Jake: But he didn't have glasses.
Jake:你现在有是吗
Jake: Do you have them now?
Jake:你没插电
Jake: You didn't plug it in.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:有勺子
Alice: There's a spoon.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:approved
Jake: Approved.
Jake:只是戴眼镜有真实感
Jake: It feels real with glasses.
Jake:卧槽涨了
Jake: Whoa, it went up.
Jake:已经涨了啊
Jake: It's already up.
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Oh my god, oh my god.
Jake:刚买就暴跌
Jake: Just bought it and it plummeted.
Jake:我靠哈哈
Jake: Damn, haha.
其他人：这个还没亏啊
Others: This hasn't lost money yet.
其他人：个我只是买了一点笔还没付出去
Others: I just bought a few pens, haven't paid out yet.
Jake:所以还能再买是吧
Jake: So you can still buy more, right?
其他人：现在就是还能有结余
Others: Yeah, there's still a surplus.
其他人：就我刚只是在充纸币
Others: I was just recharging with paper money.
Jake:哦哦还没买
Jake: Oh, you haven't bought it yet.
Jake:是还没买
Jake: So you haven't bought it yet.
其他人：对哦还没买就可以有个低价购入
Others: Yeah, you can get it at a low price.
其他人：哎到货了
Others: Hey, it arrived.
Katrina: 看看到货是啥样
Katrina: Let's see what it looks like.
其他人：然后赶紧给你买
Others: Then quickly buy it for you.
其他人：还能结余这么多笔
Others: There's still so many pens left.
其他人：我草要不要再他妈等一下
Others: Damn, should we wait a bit longer?
Katrina: ETH是什么意思
Katrina: What does ETH mean?
Katrina: 就是货币单位
Katrina: It's a currency unit.
Jake:以太坊
Jake: Ethereum.
Jake:以太坊大概就是跟比特币绑定了
Jake: Ethereum is basically tied to Bitcoin.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：买上了
Others: Bought it.
Jake:买到了
Jake: Got it.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: Got money now.
其他人：钱没了
Others: Money's gone.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 扣你多少钱
Katrina: How much did it deduct?
其他人：这个单颗80刀吧
Others: About 80 bucks per piece.
其他人：美刀新加坡的
Others: US dollars, from Singapore.
Shure: 新刀嗯
Shure: Singapore dollars, hmm.
Jake:就按照按照您这边汇率的话就480
Jake: Based on your exchange rate, it's about 480.
Jake:我就哈哈哈
Jake: I'm just, haha.
Jake:你会你跟别人不一样哈哈
Jake: You're different from others, haha.
Shure: 没有我买入的时候会会
Shure: No, when I buy, it will...
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 这皮蛋瘦肉粥还挺好喝
Katrina: This century egg and lean pork congee is pretty good.
Katrina: 这皮蛋瘦肉粥还挺好
Katrina: This century egg and lean pork congee is quite good.
其他人：哎你到了
Others: Hey, you arrived.
其他人：你给哥你找出来
Others: Find it out for bro.
其他人：留一个短头发的女生带动吧
Others: Let a short-haired girl lead it.
其他人：你俩对个暗号
Others: You two match a secret signal.
其他人：要不你打个视频
Others: How about you make a video call?
Shure: 我想死你了
Shure: I missed you so much.
Shure: 我太想你了
Shure: I really missed you.
Shure: 你都拿什么了
Shure: What did you bring?
Shure: 你把我的拿上了吗
Shure: Did you bring mine?
Shure: 有一个寸头的小姐姐
Shure: There's a girl with a buzz cut.
其他人：哦你远远远一下我瞅瞅
Others: Oh, step back a bit, let me see.
其他人：呃他可能在学校里面
Others: Uh, he might be inside the school.
其他人：找到了
Others: Found it.
其他人：放地上就行了
Others: Just put it on the ground.
其他人：他找到了
Others: He found it.
其他人：ok那我挂了886
Others: Ok, I'll hang up. Bye.
Shure: 我很想你能让我看看你吗
Shure: I miss you so much, can you let me see you?
Shure: 天哪你果然烫黑人烫去了
Shure: Oh my, you really got a perm.
Shure: 我想死你了
Shure: I missed you so much.
Shure: 我每天都在被窝里流眼泪
Shure: I cry under the covers every day.
Shure: 你怎么不让我看你
Shure: Why won't you let me see you?
Jake:早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Jake:您的眼镜对
Jake: Your glasses are right.
Jake:想他嘴巴也行
Jake: Thinking about his mouth is fine.
Jake:说的话选b调
Jake: The words he said are in B tune.
Shure: 再见
Shure: Goodbye.
Shure: 你挂的好
Shure: You hung up well.
其他人：好坚决啊
Others: So decisive.
Lucia: 这是两种粥吗
Lucia: Are these two kinds of porridge?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Uh-huh.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
Jake:买了
Jake: Bought it.
其他人：已经有了
Others: We already have it.
Jake:什么叫有了
Jake: What do you mean by "have it"?
其他人：已经有一个人
Others: Someone already bought it.
Jake:有人已经有人买了
Jake: Someone already bought it.
其他人：那不是
Others: That's not it.
其他人：我说我现在账户里已经有150个ego币了
Others: I mean, I already have 150 ego coins in my account.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:哦牛批
Jake: Oh, awesome.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Great, great.
Shure: 然后呢然后我们怎么分发呢
Shure: So how do we distribute them?
Shure: 最后会有有
Shure: In the end, we will...
Shure: 有这个Matt mask的就分
Shure: Distribute the ones with Matt mask.
Shure: 没有的就不分是吧
Shure: If you don't have it, you don't share, right?
其他人：我的想法是
Others: My idea is
其他人：最后
Others: In the end
其他人：今天大家每个人最后手里有多少个ego币
Others: Today, let's see how many ego coins everyone has at the end
Shure: 那怎么发呢
Shure: So how do we distribute it?
Shure: 那万一有人没有这个钱包呢
Shure: What if someone doesn't have this wallet?
其他人：发钱包也不
Others: Distributing wallets doesn't
其他人：要钱
Others: Cost money
其他人：但我不知道这个
Others: But I don't know if
其他人：发钱包会不会要燃油费啊
Others: Distributing wallets will require gas fees
其他人：也他妈发一个
Others: Just send one
其他人：ego币不要钱
Others: Ego coins don't cost money
其他人：燃油费他妈
Others: Gas fees are a pain
其他人：那没事我还有点余额
Others: It's okay, I still have some balance
Shure: 知道这个干嘛的吗
Shure: Do you know what this is for?
其他人：测温的
Others: For measuring temperature
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
其他人： 那你加一个面包我要先吃一下
Others: Then add a bread, I want to eat it first
Shure: 我有
Shure: I have it
Lucia: 它里面竟然是整颗雪梨
Lucia: There's a whole snow pear inside
Lucia: 我去
Lucia: Oh my
Lucia: 这比巧克力宣传整颗榛子还离谱
Lucia: This is more ridiculous than the chocolate with a whole hazelnut
Lucia: 因为它真的是整颗雪梨
Lucia: Because it's really a whole snow pear
Lucia: 你看我一捞上来我就惊呆了
Lucia: Look, I was shocked when I scooped it up
Katrina: 我需要充电宝
Katrina: I need a power bank
Lucia: 民宿的
Lucia: The homestay's
Lucia: 本来民宿的
Lucia: The homestay was supposed to
Lucia: supposed to拿我们所有人的快递
Lucia: Supposed to collect all our packages
Lucia: 你昨天应该说一声
Lucia: You should have said something yesterday
Lucia: 我要知道你没拿我们就
Lucia: If I knew you didn't take it, we would have
Tasha: 给他打电话了
Tasha: Called him
Lucia: 领导这是你的你的问题了
Lucia: Boss, this is your problem
Lucia: 领导你反思哈哈哈
Lucia: Boss, you need to reflect on this, haha
Lucia: 我那这么说来他们昨天就没拿几个
Lucia: So they didn't take many yesterday
Lucia: 咱俩那一串都没拿
Lucia: They didn't take our whole batch
Lucia: 我觉得民宿
Lucia: I think the homestay
Lucia: 他们这个工作态度要提升一下呀
Lucia: Their attitude towards work needs to improve
Lucia: 我们真的要去三亚吗
Lucia: Are we really going to Sanya?
Lucia: 还没有去过
Lucia: Never been there
Jake:你没有去过
Jake: You've never been?
Lucia: 没去过
Lucia: Never been there.
Jake:没去过走
Jake: Never been there, let's go.
Lucia: 所以您要是在三亚做实验的话
Lucia: So if you were to do experiments in Sanya
Lucia: 你看我这个工作态度和效率怎么样
Lucia: How do you think my work attitude and efficiency are?
Lucia: 哈哈哈老板你考虑一下
Lucia: Hahaha, boss, consider it.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:什么时候去
Jake: When do we go?
Jake:五一之后去走
Jake: Let's go after May Day.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Lucia: 真的吗我哈哈哈
Lucia: Really? Haha.
Alice:啊累死我了
Alice: Ah, I'm exhausted.
Lucia: 哈你这说啥我咋听不懂啊哈哈
Lucia: Haha, what are you saying? I can't understand, haha.
Lucia: 我我我因为我们家一般不说山西话
Lucia: I, I, I, because my family generally doesn't speak Shanxi dialect.
Lucia: 就是只有只有我姥姥姥爷那一辈人
Lucia: It's only my grandparents' generation.
Lucia: 他们才说山西话
Lucia: They are the only ones who speak Shanxi dialect.
Lucia: 对所以我在家其实也说普通话
Lucia: So at home, I actually speak Mandarin.
Lucia: 就是说的就说的不是很标准
Lucia: But I don't speak it very well.
Lucia: 但是我同学都说
Lucia: But my classmates all say
Lucia: 说的还可以
Lucia: That I speak it okay.
Lucia: 但是可能是同学给我给面子你知道吧
Lucia: But maybe they are just being polite, you know?
Jake:很标准了
Jake: It's pretty standard.
Shure: 完了武林外传的味上来了
Shure: It feels like a scene from "My Own Swordsman."
Lucia: 给我给武林外传的味
Lucia: It gives me "My Own Swordsman" vibes.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 佟掌柜哈哈哈
Shure: Like Tong Xiangyu, hahaha.
Jake:这太呵呵
Jake: This is too funny.
Shure: 你今天要不就一直这样
Shure: Why don't you keep it up today?
Shure: 我进来要来了呢
Shure: I'll come in and join you.
Jake:要回大掌柜吧
Jake: You should be the head shopkeeper.
Jake:要不啊呵呵呵
Jake: If not, haha.
Shure: 你你比如说那个那个有有客人来了
Shure: If, for example, a guest comes in
Shure: 你会怎么说
Shure: How would you greet them?
Shure: 用用那个山西话啊
Shure: Using the Shanxi dialect.
Shure: 不是陕西话
Shure: Not Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 吃馍还是吃还是吃啥
Lucia: Do you want steamed buns or what?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 俺也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice:他说下午统一取
Alice: He said he'll pick up this afternoon.
Alice:下午不就晚了
Alice: In the afternoon, isn't it too late?
Jake:对所以我们直接自己走
Jake: Yeah, so let's just go ourselves.
Alice:我有两个我的都到了
Alice: I have two, both of mine arrived.
Jake:好吃吃吃吃
Jake: Okay, eat eat eat.
Lucia: 可以吃它
Lucia: You can eat it.
Jake:能吃都能吃
Jake: It's all edible.
Lucia: 这里面是整颗雪梨不过已经
Lucia: Inside there's a whole snow pear, but I've
Lucia: 被我吃掉了一部分
Lucia: already eaten part of it.
Shure: 总之是有各的主要的旋律性乐器的丰
Shure: Anyway, there are various main melodic instruments.
Alice:所以什么时候拿快递啊
Alice: So when are we picking up the package?
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now, I guess.
Jake:哎谢斌竹帮忙
Jake: Hey, Xie Binzhu, help out.
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This, this one.
Jake:这你配过对吧
Jake: You've paired this before, right?
Jake:怎怎么配
Jake: How do you pair it?
Jake:就是我要跟他建立一个蓝牙
Jake: I need to establish a Bluetooth connection with it.
Jake:他是没开吗
Jake: Is it off?
Jake:他是咋回事
Jake: What's going on with it?
Alice:好鬼畜
Alice: So bizarre.
Lucia: 我一会再把头发扎一下
Lucia: I'll tie my hair up later.
Lucia: 不然他老挡着那个摄像头
Lucia: Otherwise, it keeps blocking the camera.
Shure: 俺是河南的
Shure: I'm from Henan.
Shure: 河南许昌的
Shure: From Xuchang, Henan.
Alice:口红呢
Alice: Where's the lipstick?
Lucia: 果然小醋包
Lucia: As expected, little vinegar jar.
Alice:跑哪了
Alice: Where did it go?
Alice:在这
Alice:他们已经去取快递了吗
Alice: Have they already gone to get the package?
Lucia: 应该还没走吧
Lucia: They probably haven't left yet.
Katrina: 不知道
Katrina: Don't know.
Katrina: 天天游荡着
Katrina: They wander around all day.
Lucia: 应该还在这个桌子上啊
Lucia: It should still be on this table.
Lucia: 在这在这
Lucia: Here, here it is.
Lucia: 我看见了
Lucia: I see it.
Lucia: 不过它有点不太好打着
Lucia: But it's a bit hard to light.
Lucia: 所以我用了一下就对
Lucia: So I used it just a bit.
Lucia: 感觉是你的那个棉芯
Lucia: I think it's the cotton wick.
Lucia: 现在它有点就是对
Lucia: Now it’s a bit, yeah.
Lucia: 你换一根棉芯应该就就好
Lucia: If you replace the cotton wick, it should be fine.
其他人：不是吃东西的吧
Others: It's not for eating, right?
Lucia: 不是吧昨天靖康给我的
Lucia: No, Jingkang gave it to me yesterday.
Lucia: 应该不是用来吃东西
Lucia: It probably isn't for eating.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
其他人：镊子
Others: Tweezers.
Jake:我不知道干嘛的
Jake: I have no idea what it's for.
Alice:我也有两个
Alice: I have two as well.
Jake:你也有两个
Jake: You have two as well?
Lucia: 我发到你的聊天框里吧
Lucia: I'll send it to your chat box.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh no.
Alice:这个窗户怎么办呢
Alice: What should we do about this window?
Alice:这么埋汰的颜色
Alice: Such a dirty color.
Alice:Lucy呀你
Alice: Lucia, you...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm?
Alice:你的弄了多少了
Alice: How much have you done?
Alice:你的装修进度
Alice: How's your renovation progress?
Lucia: 哇哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Wahahaha.
Lucia: 哇好好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks so good.
Alice:但我觉得这个好埋汰啊
Alice: But I think it looks so dirty.
Alice:这个灰就是这个颜色比较亮
Alice: This gray color is quite bright.
Lucia: 好看的我觉得
Lucia: I think it looks nice.
Alice:这个感觉灰不溜秋的
Alice: It feels kind of dull.
Alice:可能是印刷的问题
Alice: Maybe it's a printing issue.
Lucia: 但我觉得整体的那个什么是协调的
Lucia: But I think overall it's coordinated.
Lucia: 就是整体的色调搭配是协调
Lucia: The overall color scheme is coordinated.
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: Looks great.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe.
Lucia: 我目前为止
Lucia: Up until now,
Lucia: 还只把这个桌子摆在了墙角
Lucia: I've only put the table in the corner.
Lucia: 然后在那里放了一个照片墙哈哈
Lucia: And put a photo wall there, haha.
Alice:这是我刚贴上去的
Alice: I just put this up.
Alice:我发现还是你那个纸好用
Alice: I found your paper is better.
Lucia: 呃那个纸
Lucia: Uh, that paper.
Lucia: 我现在在想如果我贴墙上
Lucia: I'm thinking if I put it on the wall,
Lucia: 他会不会有点小
Lucia: it might be a bit small.
Lucia: 其实我觉得这个大的更好
Lucia: Actually, I think the bigger one is better.
Lucia: 就是他的视觉效果上
Lucia: In terms of visual effect,
Lucia: 会把这个房间填的更满一些
Lucia: it will fill the room more.
Alice:你买的是多大的
Alice: How big did you buy?
Lucia: 我买的不知道
Lucia: I don't know what size I bought.
Lucia: 可能不是很大
Lucia: Maybe not very big.
Lucia: 因为他是那种贴画
Lucia: Because it's a sticker.
Lucia: 就他不是
Lucia: It's not like
Lucia: 一整张画
Lucia: a whole painting
Lucia: 他是一个一个的
Lucia: It's one by one
Lucia: 你可以自己组合着贴在不同的地方
Lucia: You can stick them in different places however you like
Alice:哦那你可以稍微散一点
Alice: Oh, then you can spread them out a bit
Alice:需要我帮你啥吗
Alice: Need my help with anything?
Alice:我现在我在等我那个大那个
Alice: Right now, I'm waiting for that big, that
Alice:那个那个我的小窗帘
Alice: That, that, my small curtain
Alice:蕾丝哎
Alice: Lace, hey
Alice:不对那什么窗帘
Alice: No, what curtain
Alice:我现在想怎么给它弄上去
Alice: I'm thinking how to put it up
Lucia: 你这个你这个床罩好好看
Lucia: This bedspread of yours is so pretty
Alice:那你可以偶尔摸摸玩玩
Alice: You can touch it and play with it occasionally
Alice:无所谓的
Alice: It's fine
Alice:可以坐上来玩
Alice: You can sit on it and play
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Alice:反正他还得估计再一会去呢
Alice: Anyway, it'll take a while before it goes
Lucia: 好舒服
Lucia: So comfortable
Alice:这个床裙我很喜欢
Alice: I really like this bed skirt
Alice:就这个底下这个
Alice: The one underneath
Lucia: 嗯好看的
Lucia: Yeah, it's pretty
Lucia: 我本来也想买一个床罩
Lucia: I also wanted to buy a bedspread
Lucia: 但是我发现蓝色色调的床罩不好买
Lucia: But I found that blue-toned bedspreads are hard to find
Alice:很难买我看了
Alice: They're really hard to find, I looked
Lucia: 对非常非常不好买
Lucia: Yeah, very, very hard to find
Alice:并且颜色不好看
Alice: And the color isn't nice
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 除非就是哎
Lucia: Unless, hey
Lucia: 咱俩这很像
Lucia: Ours are quite similar
Lucia: 不过我觉得你这个大小合适
Lucia: But I think your size is just right
Lucia: 我那稍有点大了
Lucia: Mine is a bit too big
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then
Alice:我量我量了一下我这个是40直径
Alice: I measured, mine is 40 in diameter
Alice:然后就买了个60的
Alice: And then I bought a 60 one
Lucia: 我是你的同款
Lucia: I got the same model as you
Alice:你买的啥颜色呀
Alice: What color did you get?
Lucia: 蓝色的
Lucia: Blue
Alice:这个真的很好看
Alice: It really looks nice
Lucia: 嗯打算把这桌布也带回家去
Lucia: Yeah, I plan to take this tablecloth home too
Alice:这个就用完就可以带回家了
Alice: You can take it home after using it
Alice:要不然留着干嘛
Alice: Otherwise, why keep it?
Lucia: 应该是可以的
Lucia: It should be fine.
Alice:这个地毯很贵
Alice: This carpet is expensive.
Alice:花了我好多预算
Alice: It cost me a lot of my budget.
Lucia: 这是tufting的做的地毯吗
Lucia: Is this a tufted carpet?
Alice:不知道应该不是
Alice: I don't know, probably not.
Lucia: tufting就是那种毛毛毡的
Lucia: Tufting is like that fuzzy felt.
Lucia: 跟跟普通的
Lucia: Compared to regular ones.
Alice:那个大毛线突突突突突的那个
Alice: The one with big yarn that goes "tut-tut-tut-tut."
Lucia: 对对对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 是的看它有点像
Lucia: It looks a bit like it.
Alice:应该不是
Alice: Probably not.
Alice:感觉这是工厂的那啥
Alice: Feels like it's factory-made.
Alice:因为他反面是那种啥啥的工厂货
Alice: Because the back is like that typical factory stuff.
Lucia: 嗯好看的
Lucia: Hmm, it's pretty.
Alice:你需要做什么东西吗
Alice: Do you need to make something?
Alice:我可以帮你
Alice: I can help you.
Alice:虽然我有点累了
Alice: Even though I'm a bit tired.
Lucia: 嗯主要是咱们这剪刀很很急缺
Lucia: Hmm, mainly we're really short on scissors.
Lucia: 我要把那个就是墙画再剪一下
Lucia: I need to trim the wall art a bit.
Lucia: 因为我那个就他
Lucia: Because it's supposed to be...
Lucia: 本来他是直接撕下来就贴到墙上的
Lucia: Originally, it's supposed to be peeled off and stuck on the wall.
Lucia: 但我害怕贴到这的墙上
Lucia: But I'm afraid if I stick it to this wall...
Lucia: 万一到时候撕掉就很麻烦
Lucia: It'll be a hassle to peel off later.
Lucia: 所以我要把它剪下来
Lucia: So I need to cut it off...
Lucia: 然后用美纹纸贴
Lucia: And use masking tape to stick it.
Lucia: 让我先上去把它拿下来
Lucia: Let me go up and get it first.
Alice:要不你在我这弄吧
Alice: How about you do it at my place?
Lucia: 也可以会
Lucia: That works too.
Alice:我这还放了香薰嘞
Alice: I even have aromatherapy here.
Lucia: 我看看昨天晚上那个剪刀
Lucia: Let me check the scissors from last night.
Lucia: 我剪那个啥
Lucia: I used them to cut...
Lucia: 我剪那个塑料瓶用了一下
Lucia: I used them to cut the plastic bottle.
Alice:好
Alice:话说我们甜品是不是应该先做着呀
Alice: By the way, should we make the dessert first?
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia: 我觉得我是不是
Lucia: I think I...
Lucia: 嗯这个天气有点暗
Lucia: Hmm, the weather is a bit gloomy.
Alice:我感觉我上火了露西
Alice: I feel like I'm getting a cold, Lucia.
Alice:我的鼻子好痛
Alice: My nose really hurts.
Lucia: 嗯多
Lucia: Hmm, more...
Alice:我的牙龈也好痛
Alice: My gums hurt too.
Lucia: 多喝点水
Lucia: Drink more water.
Alice:确实你提醒我了
Alice: You're right, thanks for reminding me.
Lucia: 我觉得我也有点
Lucia: I think I have it too.
Lucia: 而且我就是一直会想打喷嚏
Lucia: And I just keep wanting to sneeze.
Lucia: 为什么又找不见剪刀了
Lucia: Why can't I find the scissors again?
Lucia: 好烦啊
Lucia: So annoying.
Lucia: 严重拖慢我的进度
Lucia: It's seriously slowing me down.
Lucia: 本来是进度就不怎么快
Lucia: My progress was already slow to begin with.
Lucia: 莫非能在楼上吗
Lucia: Could they be upstairs?
Lucia: 我昨天没用它了呀
Lucia: I didn't use them yesterday.
Lucia: 我就在楼下最后用了一下
Lucia: I just used them downstairs last.
Lucia: 然后我就没用了
Lucia: And then I didn't use them again.
Lucia: 不知道呀
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 好奇怪呀
Lucia: It's so weird.
Lucia: 我上楼看一眼
Lucia: I'll check upstairs.
Lucia: 要剪不好
Lucia: If I can't cut it well...
Lucia: 那我就GG
Lucia: Then I'm done for.
Alice:你找到了吗
Alice: Did you find them?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Alice:哎我的天呀
Alice:好晒啊今天
Alice: It's so sunny today.
Alice:美丽的小姐
Alice: Beautiful lady.
Katrina: 天呐
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina: 做的跟坨屎一样
Katrina: It looks like a pile of crap.
Katrina: 真的会有人
Katrina: Seriously, will anyone...
Alice:找到了吗
Alice: Did you find it?
Lucia: 好奇怪
Lucia: That's so strange.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上在那里用的
Lucia: I used it there last night.
Lucia: 然后就还放在那了
Lucia: And then I just left it there.
Lucia: 好怪啊
Lucia: So weird.
Alice:嗯嗯嗯
Alice: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Lucia: 理论上说他应该
Lucia: Theoretically, it should...
Lucia: 他应该不可能不见呀
Lucia: It shouldn't be able to disappear.
Lucia: 咱这饮料可真多呀
Lucia: We sure have a lot of drinks here.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 美工刀给他放架子上去
Lucia: Put the utility knife on the shelf.
Lucia: 而且那个剪刀它整体还是个透明的
Lucia: And the scissors are completely transparent.
Lucia: 特别不好找
Lucia: Really hard to find.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 那个剪刀它整体是透明的
Lucia: That pair of scissors is entirely transparent.
Lucia: 绝对不好找
Lucia: It's definitely hard to find.
Alice:这豆还洒了
Alice: The beans are spilled too.
Lucia: 对那昨天晚上洒的
Lucia: Yeah, they spilled last night.
Alice:这已经开了
Alice: This one's already open.
Lucia: 我操啊完全找不到
Lucia: Damn it, I can't find it at all.
Alice:现在只有一个了是吗
Alice: So there's only one left now, right?
Lucia: 嗯而且是不好用的那个
Lucia: Yeah, and it's the one that doesn't work well.
Alice:要不你先用着
Alice: How about you use it for now?
Lucia: 那个应该雨轩现在在用吧
Lucia: Rain might be using it now.
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 那个我也没找着
Lucia: I couldn't find it either.
Lucia: 就是所有的剪刀
Lucia: Like, all the scissors...
Lucia: 都不见了
Lucia: ...are missing.
Lucia: 到底啥情况
Lucia: What's going on?
Alice:要不用这个
Alice: How about using this one?
Lucia: 这个我昨天也用了
Lucia: I used this one yesterday too.
Lucia: 但是他没有剪刀
Lucia: But it doesn't work like scissors.
Lucia: 灵活就我昨天切瓶子时候用了
Lucia: I used it to cut the bottle yesterday.
Lucia: 我刚把它放到这其实
Lucia: I just put it here actually.
Lucia: 我靠好奇怪呀
Lucia: Gosh, it's so weird.
Lucia: 他怎么能就没有了呢
Lucia: How could it just disappear?
Lucia: 我在群里问一下吧
Lucia: I'll ask in the group chat.
Alice:就蒸蛋蒸的不错
Alice: The steamed egg turned out well.